[Music]
nine
loss
nine complete
the loss of everything
seven
loneliness
four tell
nine complete
i want to tell you about absolute
loneliness
18
6
father
stan are you okay
yeah keep going we got two shows
tomorrow
loneliness
two
fear
emphasis on detail circle
a prophecy fulfilled
wait
a woman
can you be more specific
it issues r or s
r
yes
yes oh
i believe you know to whom i'm speaking
now do you not
you're correct again
messed up
[Applause]
all we do is rehearse and you still
fluff it i'll do it by myself what
happened i'm sorry i guess i was tired
let's see how many people stay for the
second show
pocket watch
gold
concentrate do any other details come to
you
there is an inscription
letters am i correct
you are
master stanton can you kind of name them
yes please give me the option no thank
you i'll hold it very
well master stanton what is the object
being held by this lady
well it seems it's a night of gold a
golden handbag
be quiet child
let me ask the questions
what is inside the bag
madam
what is the meaning of this
you say you're genuine and i say you use
verbal signals of some sort to
communicate between the two of you
there are no tricks involved madam
there's no deception whatsoever
then answer me
what is inside the bag
the usual's inside that bag
lipstick a handkerchief oh that is easy
enough is it not
ladies and gentlemen i've never met this
woman before
nor have i any prior knowledge to the
contents of that purse yet
yes there is something very interesting
in there
a small pistol
nickel plated ivory handle
man
you claim to carry it to
defend yourself but
i think you do it because you like it
i think you do it because
it makes you feel
powerful
well madam
you are not powerful
not powerful enough
you are an only child are you not your
mother died when you were young
her shadow looms large and close too
close for comfort hardly a day went by
in which she didn't crush you down in
small ways
and that gun
that gun in your purse
well
sometimes you have dark thoughts about
yourself don't you
well don't you
you're an issue
cake yes
have you suffered a loss of dear one
that long ago oh god julian
god
he's right beside you
his hand is resting on your right
shoulder can you feel it
yes he wants you to know something
he wants you to know
how proud he is of you
and how
[Music]